48 hours after the horror in uvalde
texas anger
anguish and frankly exhaustion just pure
exhaustion over the senseless acts of
violence we're seeing in this country
this is entertainment tonight you know
from anderson cooper's gut-wrenching
interview with the father of one of the
victims to jimmy kimmel's latest
impassioned plea raw emotions are on
full display
[Music]
once again we grieve
for the uh
little boys and girls
there have been 27 school shootings so
far this year in this country and it's
may
how does this make sense
to anyone
in uvalde a memorial outside rob
elementary school grows one cross planet
for each of the 19 children and two
teachers who are now gone today meghan
markle made a surprise appearance and
placed down white flowers at another
vigil nearby
it's
too much journalists now grapple to
maintain composure after speaking with
heartbroken parents who just want to
know why what would you want people to
know about your ellie jesus he died for
us so when we die
we'll be up there for him and i had the
honor who founded her
she just turned 10 two weeks ago
you know it's the details uh
it's just really hard here i'm joined
now by cbs morning co-host tony decouple
from uvalde texas and he's talked to amy
garza's father angel and it was an
emotional conversation within minutes he
breaks down and when he starts to do
that all of us are breaking down as well
what we learned is
that amory was trying to call for help
as her father had taught her to do
the moment she was cut down
by a deranged madman he said this off
camera he knows his daughter's final
moments were pure
and absolute terror anderson cooper also
tried to comfort amerie's dad as he
revealed the devastating way he learned
of her death one little girl was just
just covered in blood saying that they
shot her best friend and asked the
little girl
the name and she's
and she told me she said amory
that's how you learn
how do you look at this girl in shooter
oh a baby how do you shoot my baby
if you can watch that interview that
father and you feel like no action needs
to be taken stay away from me that's
what i'm saying they're far away from me
something's got to be done